resident evil 7 beginning our may just
be a demo but that hasn't stopped fans
from digging through to uncover every
secret they found alternate endings and
creepy ghost sightings but one object
still remains a mystery the dummy finger
it looks a bit like a key but what could
it open Capcom has finally weighed in on
the issue in an email to resident evil
ambassador program members Capcom
attached an image of the dummy finger
atop a note the note reads the path for
now is closed but patience the message
implies that the dummy finger may find a
use in the future perhaps even in the
full game fans have pointed out that the
image shows a calendar open to the month
of September so we might hear more then
gamespot has reached out to capcom for
further comment resident evil 7 comes to
ps4 xbox one and pc on january twenty
four twenty seventeen the game is set
after the events of Resident Evil 6 but
other than that we don't know who the
protagonist is or where the game takes
place but if you want to keep up with
all the Resident Evil news you're
already in the right place